[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jennifer
is in Columbia South Carolina hi
Jennifer how are you hello hey what's
up yeah um well I wanted to ask you a
question um my husband and I we're
having issues just saving and staying
afloat and we're really considering
doing that Cash out refinance on our
home
um because it just seems like the only
way we'll be able to get out the rut and
save and eliminate it how much debt do
you
have um I have between about 880,000 my
husband is probably like 300K but that
includes the house okay how much debt
does he have separate from the
house um I'll say
[Music]
probably 50 60 and what kind of debt is
this combined is it student loans credit
cards yeah it's just loans credit card
my in student
loans um and that's really the gist of
it and just how much
cars I'm sorry how much is
cars um it's we have one car and it's
40,000 okay one you have one paid for
car or I'm sorry one car with a car note
or do you have two cars and you have a
paid for car sitting there as well just
one car with a car Noe okay um what's
your household
income um well my husband makes between
200k a year um and I make 21 and then he
also had we both have
disability you make $21,000 and he makes
$200,000 yes and you said you both have
disability explain
that um cuz we both were veterans so we
do have a disability income and how much
is that in addition to um it's it's
probably a extra 20K um on to our income
but it's just like can I can I be honest
with you y'all make far too much money
to be this
broke yeah you make 200 you have
$221,000 coming in a year 50,000 coming
in yeah 200 yeah even more that's
unbelievable quart of a million dollars
a
year Yan you're spending like you're in
Congress and you have $130,000 of debt
here's here's what I'm telling you and I
want you to really understand this if
you just lived lived on half of what you
make which is still more than the
average family in America almost double
the average family you would be out of
debt and it wouldn't take you borrowing
on your mortgage to do it or refinancing
or cash Ting your mortgage borrowing on
the mortgage is absolutely the most
horrible ridiculous thing you can do
because it will enable you to consider
this chaotic out of control disorganized
over spending life and you're going to
gra crash this
car girl I I mean you guys got to know
you got to get control you know that
don't
you yeah yeah so the house uh what's
your what's your mortgage payment what
are you paying on this
house uh well it went up to $1,900 it
was
,100 um all right so that's not your
problem it's just your living I I I
already know the answer to this but
you're not on a budget
correct I I mean I feel like we are we
don't do anything yeah but that's not
the
same okay
$250,000 is going somewhere aren't you
kind of curious where it went I am I I
am yeah yeah yeah I think it's kind of
like
whoa this is a mystery so um what does
your husband do for a living he's a
truck driver and that that's where I
wanted to get into he's a truck driver
and he'll go to work and it'll be times
where um because the fuel prices are so
high everything he comes out of pocket
he's on a1099 but he works with the
company and um you don't make wait a
minute he does not make $200,000 a year
yeah he grosses $200,000 a year but his
net income after expenses he's an owner
operator
right yes there's the problem he's not
netting
200,000 okay he's running a business
that brings in 200,000 and then he has
repairs and Fuel and other things out of
that am I
correct yes okay so you do not have an
income of 200,000 your income is the net
profit on his business after expenses
are paid which is more like 100,000 that
sounds right okay uh does that sound
right to you yeah that probably sounds
better yeah okay so Jennifer what do you
do what's your job well I just finished
I just finished school I'm an
esthetician and I'm trying to start my
business um and you know I've been an at
home mom but now um you know but I'm
also trying to start a business but I
want to challenge you I want I want to
challenge you with your esthetician work
right now it sounds like it's more like
quarter time to part-time based on your
earnings am I right well my income comes
from disability so you haven't earned
you're 21 you haven't earned anything
from this degree yet right I just
graduated probably like two Fridays ago
oh okay well congratulations that's
great okay you here's what we're going
to do all right I'm going to we're going
to set you into Financial Peace
University it includes a budgeting G app
called every dollar and then the other
thing you ought to do is you ought to
contact a ramsy coach in your area you
can find them online with us at Ramsey
Solutions and sit down with them because
someone needs to help you guys put
together a set of books for his business
and now for your business so you
actually know what profit you have after
taxes are paid and after the expenses of
the business are paid and then you will
know what it takes to attack this debt
it sounds to me like you're $40,000 car
probably needs to be sold yeah CU I
think it's too much car in this
situation and my guess is you probably
have a very high interest rate on it and
the reason you have only have one car
that's super expensive is he's in a
truck all the time he's over the road
and an owner operator
so you you guys need you guys need to
get your uh your your net profits
figured out so that you can get
organized and get on a budget and begin
to attack the these debts and we're
going to list them smallest to largest
and you're going to be able to do it in
that order I thought for a few minutes
there you had a $250,000 income and that
was super absurd that you couldn't pay
off $140,000 worth of debt making that
but you don't you have probably a
$100,000 $120,000 income give or take
and uh that's still enough to get you
out of debt but it's not it doesn't make
you look as uh out of control as I
initially thought you were okay you you
know all it means is you're you're right
your budget is probably not super got
all kind you know you're probably not
eating caviar every night or something
here it's not that's not what's going on
but uh but but you are going to have to
tighten up and you are going to have to
make a decision and it's probably going
to take you about 3 years of sacrifice
including selling this car and getting a
much more reasonable cheap car
temporarily to get yourself out of into
control but we'll get you started in
Financial Peace University and get you
started on the every dollar budget and
help you get moving